Next up, and lastly, we've got the landmass tool.
So we can enable landmass from the plugin.
So if you unsure where your plugins window is, you just go to edit at the top of your
browser, go down to plugins, you can either just type landmass in the search bar, or you
can find it in the other tab.
When you enable that, your editor will likely want to restart.
So just go ahead and restart your editor, and then we can move on to the next step.
So we can still create a new landscape using landmass.
So we want to open up landscape tool, make a new landscape, any size again, however you
would like to make that look, and just make sure that enable edit layers is enabled.
The landmass tools require that setting as we used last time, in order for these to work.
And then we have a few different options available to us.
So we want to make sure we're in landscape sculpt mode, which is the setting that we
used previously.
And then from the quick add in the project menu, we want to look for the custom brush
landmass.
So with this little icon, you can just type in landmass.
And this act will allow you to control the location that landscape will be affected by
the brush.
So we can add more points from this brush when we've dragged it in.
You can add more points by selecting one and pressing alt whilst dragging exactly how we
did with the spline tool in the landscape.
So we can just make these different shapes using this custom brush landmass, which then
you can edit over the top of.
So you can see that we can start getting some really cool results here.
We can also use the material to offset the landscape.
So if we wanted to add a change any settings here, here are some example brush settings,
which is a simple brush where you can see that that just adds a lot of interest to the
environment.
So you can do that by first setting the brush type to material only.
So you can see brush type is material only.
And then to adjust the look, you just offset what you need to do in the brush material.
So when you can see that we've masked out some information here in our sample simple
brush and you can see that landscape then gets edited based on this material information,
which is pretty cool.
And then we can also do some more custom things here.
So we can use a material to offset the landscape.
So again, material only, but we want to, so we want to set the material to material only.
And then to adjust the look of the offset, we just need to, again, just use this custom
override material where you can see that there's now the Unreal Engine logo, which is you just
tick the override material.
So even though we had a simple brush material to begin with, you have an override material
as well.
So here's an example of the material.
So to make the material work with this, the material needs to be unlit.
So make sure your material setup is unlit and use two material functions.
So we want to unpack RGB height here.
And this is for unpacking brush data into a format that can be worked into the editor.
And then we also want to pack the RGB height.
And this is repackaging the brush into something that will work with landmass.
So these two functions that highlighted, that's what you'll need to make your material work.
And then the material was converted into a material instance to make it easier to work
with the landmass system.
So once you've created this, you can change that texture sample into a parameter if you
want.
Just turn it into a material instance because then that makes the editing easier.
For a more in-depth example, check out the default landmass brush.